faire des milliers de kilomètres sans
s'arrêter avait des comme on pense à la
route de demain pour les véhicules
électriques etc cette piste de recharge
grâce à des bobines communicants entre
la voiture et la route les beautés la
piste et d'y augmenter sa autonomie dont
la ville c'est la technologie est le
plus intéressant encore parce qu' on a
des endroits où les véhicules roulent
moins vite
donc ils ont des vents défaut rouge il
s'arrête complètement
il ya ces moments là si la piste des
vents de faux le faut il va séchage et
plus
cette piste est l'un des sujets de
recherche de l'institut basé à
versailles vd comme célèbre cette année
ses cinq ans navettes autonome création
de start up aux études des flux de
mobilité la toute première nouveauté
c'est le bâtiment au sein duquel nous
sommes celles au mobile app puisque nous
avons fédéré toutes nos équipes dans un
seul bâtiment
c'est un emplacement dans lequel nous
étudions la mobilité du futur et nous y
menons des activités qui concerne à la
fois l'électrification du véhicule nous
y travaillons également sur tout ce qui
est technologique lié à la perception à
la localisation du véhicule autonome
ainsi que les facteurs humains vd comme
aujourd'hui ce sont 200 employés des
chercheurs pour plus de la moitié
l'institut signe aussi des partenariats
le groupe ratp est devenu aujourd'hui
l'un des nouveaux membres pour réfléchir
à des transports publics autonomes